tell us a little bit about your life
Hannah uh like from birth or yeah yeah I
want to say I'm not going to start from
birth but I'm going to say start from
like 4 hours after birth you've been
cleaned Post in you're wrapped uh you're
under heat lamp no I just meant uh I
want to get a sense of do you live in
Vancouver full-time uh what do you do so
I work on boats like yachts and so I'm
always in and out whenever I get any
holiday or any leave I come home to see
family and friends but I'm not
permanently here when you you say you
work on the boats you mean not building
the boats but but living on the boat and
helping people is that what you do yeah
so I'm not a Craftsman but I am a chef
on a oh okay you're a chef on a
boat okay well recently my wife got
started uh I had to travel a lot she
took a lover which she tends to do when
I leave town it yeah it was it was gorle
they're quite she's quite happy when
she's with him
uh he apparently listens to her um but
uh no I I got back and she had become
hooked on um below deck the reality show
and there's one I guess that takes place
in
Australia and it's like below Deck Down
Under And um yeah and it's this exactly
it's below deck down under which I
thought was ridiculous um but uh yeah so
I'm just curious if it's at all like
that when you watch a cuz what you see
on that show is all the people running
around uh um getting on each other's
nerves in a very contained space is that
at all what it's like when you're
working on a yacht uh I haven't seen the
show myself but I've Got Friends that
watch and from what I gather it's
similar but obviously a dramatized
version of reality right but it is a
very small space to live and work
together with a small group of people so
I also think I have to say I think being
a chef would Be Tough Enough MH but to
be a chef on a boat where if you
suddenly need something oh we need
paprika we need non-fat yogurt we need
uh iceberg lettuce and you can't get it
because you're at Sea plus the boat's
constantly moving it sounds like it's 10
times harder than being a just a a
regular Chef I mean you make Provisions
for that you try to stock up on as much
as possible if people are coming on
board you get a list of their
preferences dislikes Etc so you try to
prepare accordingly but yes there's
always the occasional thing where you'll
be in the middle of nowhere and someone
wants mini cucumbers I don't know
something and you have to try to find
that so let me guess it's it's mostly
rich people affluent people that you're
waiting on if they're living on a yacht
yes I yeah that's pretty much the are
you ever tempted to say no we don't have
it you know no sorry we don't we don't
have that you're on a boat get your
thumb out of your ass do you ever say
that to
anybody uh thankly I'm not front facing
it's always the other staff who have to
deal with the guest face to face I'm in
the galley tucked away it's nice so we
can get the order and we can all stare
at each other in disbelief and then we
can proceed versus them they have to
listen to this person making an insane
request and they have to smile and right
and if so so they're the one that's
hearing I would like um I would like a
pistachio vanilla moose three tiered
cake that's decorated only with yellow
M&M's and then they come down and they
tell you and you guys stand around in
the kitchen and talk about them for
like 15 minutes right I heard you
ordering that the other day I like that
okay and I demand it I see why you're
asking David you know me you know I'm an
electric vehicle Enthusiast you are and
I'm excited very excited I'll tell you
why the all new all electric check it
out not two Row three row so many people
Kia ev9 that's more people than I'm
friendly with this thing's incredible
just off the top of my head the Kia ev9
is the first three Row Mass Market EV
SUV try saying EV SUV three times fast
hey 800 volt Ultra fast DC charging 10%
to 80% in 24 minutes at compatible 350
kilowatt Chargers W that's impressive
yeah if I understood what that meant I
too would be impressed also check this
out SiriusXM offers a 3mon 3 month trial
subscription to all equipped Kia
vehicles Sirus XM provides access to
over 165 plus channels they got
everything sports news comedy con and
O'Brien radio I was waiting for that and
you know what's very cool I was curious
I was thinking I can talk about this car
but I haven't really seen it and Kia
said yeah you want to see one we'll send
one over for you to check out they're
going to make me wear special gloves and
I can't keep it I can just look at it
but uh I'm very excited for us to see it
very excited about that the all new all
electric three row Kia ev9 visit kia.com
ev9 to learn more Kia movement that
inspires it sounds like it would be
that's a how long have you been doing
this for uh on and off for the last nine
years so once I finished University I
started doing this and yeah that sounds
I mean first of all it's very romantic
to go to see I think that's that sounds
really cool you know to yeah okay you
just your yeah made it sound like no
it's not enthusiasm wan there for a
second um it can be there's lots of nice
plates if you get a go that I would
never choose to travel to like it'll be
a very small tiny Island in Greece for
example which is lovely but you get to
see different parts of the world from a
boat that you wouldn't say versus a
normal road trip Etc so that's nice have
you ever crossed the ocean the Atlantic
Ocean I think this last fall I did my
sixth Crossing so oh wow wow that's cool
never crossed an ocean on a boat that's
probably on a bucket list for me I'd
love to do that obviously my ancestors
did it when they were asked to leave
Ireland um when you get asked to leave
America yeah exactly maybe I'll do it
then um that is uh I I have to say
that's very impressive that sounds like
now do you think this is your going to
be your gig for the long run or do you
see something else for you in the future
at a certain point is being on a boat
been like been there done that well it's
very fun but it is a very weird
existence where you're sharing a room
with somebody you've got a bunk or
someone's above you or below it's just a
very bizarre life as an adult with
sharing a bunk who's not your sibling um
so that's strange so I don't see this
forever but I figure keep doing it until
I stop enjoying it and I still enjoy it
so um I'm going to get real personal
here this does not include you but I'm
just saying are there there's got to be
hookups on a boat I mean Sona come on
weigh in there yeah I said people be
okay well okay no I'm sorry Bo
Hannah she's Hannah do people be
yeah no Hannah's she's from Vancouver
they're very lovely people people in
Vancouver don't be don't stop
saying that it's not cool I'm uh H I
apologize from my very crash friend but
um uhoh there she is no I think she it
looked like you froze on Zoom but I
think you froze because of the course
language oh sorry I mean people be
making love yeah make but that must it
must get complicated when you have men
women hormone small boat yes yeah I'm
not gonna name names no of course not I
would never ask you to we'll do that on
a separate phone call yeah I would post
um there's definitely been you see why
there's a TV show made after this
because there's been some pretty absurd
situations of say someone being romantic
with someone and then perhaps pursuing
somebody else y that's in the same
department and you're all in this little
boat and to say the least it all gets
around yeah everyone finds out there's
no way this stuff happened on Moby Dick
you know I mean any classic sea tail
there's always people hooking up yeah
yeah yeah yeah I don't I would I would
forget the boat's not mine yeah that's
probably true at some point how do you
mean like I would start to be like is
this my boat This Is My Yacht and then I
would start sleeping in like their M
main bedroom and stuff like does anyone
do do do that is that just you're like a
Goldie L we have um I mean
perhaps okay son is on to something here
yeah that's interesting well on a
Crossing you'll have some captains that
are very kind and generous and they let
crew use the guest areas when we're on a
Crossing because there's no guest on
board but typically it's you have to
wear white gloves and not touch anything
in the guest quarters so um can I ask
you uh Hannah you might be somewhat
familiar with this show or or with my
general personality do you think I would
do well on a long Crossing or would I
instantly go quite
mad so the thing is it's be honest be
honest it's a small space and typically
if you're in a marina you can step off
have some space to yourself but on a
Crossing it's you realize just how tiny
it is and people tend to go a little
nuts I think you would try and entertain
everybody I would but also can I say
something Hannah that could be a problem
I think You' start eating other people
even know there's full provisions on
board yeah they'd make you walk the
plank I I would start I would start
drinking my own urine even though there
was plenty of water I would do it as a
culinary
Choice um no but but I but that I think
one of the problems might be um as you
guys work in a small space with me and
uh I'm I'm looking uh at at four people
right now who are in a very small space
with me on a regular basis and we'll
just do an hour together together and I
can see that you guys are ready to time
out me on a boat on a six- day Crossing
in a confined space saying hey Hannah
what about this
bit I mean do you think I'd be killed
like two days in I personally not by me
but perhaps everybody else speak to them
um an I don't think you could possibly
understand what you're in for you know
what I love Hannah didn't say not by me
but maybe by someone else she said not
by me but by everybody
it would be murder on the or Express the
the answer is everybody did everybody I
think you would take on a Persona I
think you'd like think you were a pirate
and then you would start talking like
one and a captain I would bring a
stuffed pirrot and glue it to my
shoulder